Film Courage: What’s the first step in writing
a screenplay, either for television or feature
film?
Daniel Calvisi: Well, I think it’s making
sure that your concept can sustain a full
feature film or a series.
Now in TV it’s trickier here because you
not only need to have a great pilot (which
is one episode of your show) but you need
to have a concept that can sustain a series
for multiple seasons.
So you need to have what a friend of mine
called a playground (a dramatic playground)
which is you create this very specific world
and then you put these very interesting characters
into it to play and bang against each other
and have lots of dramatic conflict.
If that idea is something that can sustain
and run for awhile, maybe that’s a better
idea for TV.
Whereas feature films have closed endings,
so you are going to have an idea with a beginning,
middle and end.
And that’s pretty much that.
Film Courage: Okay.
Let’s take the feature film scenario.
So [what is] the first step in writing a screenplay
for a feature film?
Daniel Calvisi: I would say story mapping
it out.
If you have a concept that you think is great
and you’re passionate about it and you want
to write it, write a story map (which is your
basic outline).
So it’s going to be for 8 to 12 major signpost
beats and your 4 story engines and you’re
going to define your core elements first (what
I call the basic story map), which is your
protagonist, their external and internal goal,
the main dramatic conflict standing in the
way of that goal that is going to generate
all those obstacles that are really going
to sustain the story.
Your controlling theme which is your major
meta theme that you are going to be exploring,
and then a few other elements like your protagonist.
You want to have your skill, their misbehavior
(a misbehavior is a quirk or personality trait
that consistently generates conflict) and
then their achilles heel which is just that
thing that could destroy them, could potentially
destroy them.
So once you have those core elements and then
you have the major signpost beats of your
outline, then you are ready to do a full scene
outline and then jump in and write pages.
Film Courage: What is the first step in writing
a screenplay for a TV series?
Daniel Calvisi: I would always say start the
story as late as possible, enter the story
as late as possible so you don’t have much
set-up and so the story can get going right
away.
Film Courage: Do you think sometimes new writers
they overwrite and it’s too dense and they
are giving us too much backstory?
Daniel Calvisi: Yeah…too much set-up.
You don’t need that much set-up.
Maybe you’re opening with a flash forward
like in Breaking Bad.
It’s like BOOM!
- we are in this intense scene where there
is this guy in his underwear driving an RV
like a bat out of hell and he has a gas mask
on.
And he crashes the RV and in the script he
(Brian Cranston) was called underwear man
before we find out his character’s name
was Walter White.
But they just BOOM!
dropped us right into the action and that
is something that really grabs a reader.